[Música]
vamos a las noticias de la salud con más
Romero salamar Buen día para usted
Buenos días Ángela una noticia bien
innovadora Inteligencia artificial que
sigue ocupando nuestros saberes
periodísticos gracias a una nueva
tecnología mar un equipo científico
encontró un nuevo antibiótico potencial
Cómo fue el camino Sí una nueva noticia
como decía sobre Inteligencia artificial
que en este caso nos muestra también las
bondades no las posibilidades que tienen
estos nuevos algoritmos en este caso lo
usaron varias universidades de Canadá y
de Estados Unidos que Se juntaron para
hacer este estudio y encontraron el
componente llamado abaucín es un
componente que parece enfrentar una
bacteria responsable de infecciones
pulmonares responsable también de
infecciones sanguíneas voy a decir bien
su nombre es acitenovactor baumani es
una conocida una bacteria conocida como
estás súper bacterias es decir que es
una de las más resistentes a
tratamientos y a los antibióticos que
existen hoy en día y de hecho está
listada por la Organización Mundial de
la Salud como una de las más peligrosas
a una de las que más retos nos va a
poner en los próximos años cómo hizo
entonces este equipo de investigación
para usar la Inteligencia artificial lo
primero que hicieron fue entrenar esta
Inteligencia artificial cogieron muchos
componentes químicos ya conocidos
tratamientos ya conocidos y lo
enfrentaron a esta bacteria para ver
cuáles podían tener un efecto en
retrasar su crecimiento o en hacerle
algún tipo de daño y alimentaron el
algoritmo de la Inteligencia artificial
con toda esta información ya conocida
luego lo que hicieron fue que el
algoritmo revisara más de
6.600 componentes nuevos que no se
conocía Qué impacto podían tener en esta
bacteria y el algoritmo la Inteligencia
artificial este mecanismo lo que logró
fue producir una lista corta de unos 240
potenciales componentes es decir reducir
de estos más de 6.600 a 240 así el
equipo investigador pudo estos 240
componentes llevarlos al laboratorio e
irlos probando para ver cuál realmente
tenía un Y así fue que encontraron este
aboucín que realmente Parece ser
fulminante contra contra este organismo
es una tarea que de otra forma hubiera
sido demasiado larga y demasiado
laboriosa Como para verla hecho
manualmente pero pues gracias a esta
Inteligencia artificial fue posible
bueno eso le iba a decir podrían ser
incluso hasta años de investigación que
se ahorraron totalmente con una muy
buena herramienta años y recursos bueno
la investigación sobre la resistencia de
las bacterias a los antibióticos mar es
primordial como ustedes ya nos dejaba
ver al principio sí es primordial y de
hecho se nos suele olvidar No mucho no
es algo de lo que hablemos tanto Pero
sabemos que décadas de uso de los
antibióticos o especialmente de mal uso
de los antibióticos ha hecho que las
bacterias puedan adaptarse puedan
evolucionar y haciendo que los
antibióticos resultado también de
décadas de investigación se han inútiles
eso puede implicar que una pequeña
herida si se infecta pueda terminar
siendo fatal o que haya cirugías que no
se pueden hacer cirugías muy invasivas
que se logran a tratar tratamientos
antibióticos de los pacientes para que
puedan sanar estas heridas producto de
las cirugías y que dejen de ser posibles
o sean muy peligrosas muy riesgosas
hacerlo y es un problema no tan
investigado en parte también porque es
poco rentable es decir las farmacéuticas
están mucho más interesadas por ejemplo
pues desde una visión empresarial en
desarrollar tratamientos contra
enfermedades crónicas del cáncer es del
gran ejemplo es un mercado que ahora
mismo da muchísimo dinero que no para
desarrollar un antibiótico nuevo que al
final te tomas 20 pastillas y las dejas
de necesitar no Entonces eso también
provoca que haya tan poca investigación
y que en este caso sea tan importante
este nuevo avance que estamos hablando
Vamos a repasar las cifras para
dimensionar el problema no en 2019 la
resistencia bacterial provocó una como
27 millones de muertes directas y casi 5
millones de muertes indirectas es decir
que participó de alguna forma que
hubiera una infección de una bacteria
resistente a los antibióticos vemos que
las principales son infecciones
respiratorias y sanguíneas en en este
caso por lo tanto la bacteria de la que
hablábamos al principio justamente
responsable de este tipo de infecciones
y por eso puede ser importante es una
muy buena noticia definitivamente aunque
también recordar que estamos en el
primer paso ahora que tenemos este
componente hace falta desarrollar un
fármaco y hace falta hacer los ensayos
clínicos para ver cómo funciona pero sí
es una buena noticia No claro siempre es
bueno celebrar los pasos hacia adelante
mar hay otro tema que está bien
interesante y ese que un grupo de
científicos Ha logrado inducir un estado
de hibernación en ratas y esto gracias a
un ultrasonido háblenos de esto sí es un
estudio muy curioso hecho en una pequeña
cantidad de animales pero vamos a hablar
de eso porque es bien Es bien
interesante lo que lograron fue inducir
un estado que se llama actor porque es
parecido a la hibernación en animales
que es cuando Pues no hay comida o hay
temperaturas muy bajas entran en este
estado para tratar de sobrevivir el
equipo que es de la Universidad de
Washington en San Luis Estados Unidos lo
que hicieron fue enganchar una especie
de altavoz ultrasónico en la cabeza de
los animales y al dirigía estas ondas a
la zona del hipotálamo que es la zona
central profunda del cerebro y gracias a
eso observaban cómo bajaba la
temperatura de los animales como bajaba
también su ritmo metabólico y lograron
mantener esto durante 24 horas cuando se
apagaba el dispositivo los ratones
volvían a su estado normal Aparentemente
sin mayor problema Aunque obviamente
hará falta investigar más para saber si
no tiene consecuencias no interesante
porque lo probaron con ratones que
entran naturalmente en torpor es decir
tienen este estado incluido en sus
herramientas digamos pero en ratas que
no lo tienen no no son animales que
entren en hibernación naturalmente
Aunque en ese caso funcionó mucho peor
el experimento Así que esa es una de las
limitaciones del estudio entre muchas
diría yo quisiera preguntarle qué es lo
que motiva este tipo de investigaciones
claro yo yo creo que al final el Enigma
de la hibernación en animales de si es
posible inducirla en animales que
naturalmente no lo hacen nos hace
preguntar también
si es posible a largo plazo en los
humanos No si habría posibilidad de
despertar o de desbloquear esta
capacidad de hibernar o de inducir
estados de metabolismo bajo en el caso
de los humanos de hecho en las
conclusiones de los estudios los mismos
autores destacan haberlo que haberlo
logrado como decíamos en las ratas que
no hiberna naturalmente Abre esa puerta
y que eso podría tener aplicaciones
médicas por ejemplo cuando hay un ataque
al corazón reducir el ritmo metabólico
de las personas puede ser positivo para
evitar los daños porque hace que las
células o las neuronas necesiten menos
oxígeno pero es que luego también hablan
de los viajes de los vuelos espaciales
de larga duración que es de esa un poco
esa fantasía casi de ciencia ficción de
poder dormir a los astronautas dentro de
unas cápsulas y enviarlos a hacer viajes
interestelares sin que haya daños en las
personas entonces eso bueno también
claramente es una de las cosas que
señalan aunque por supuesto estamos muy
lejos de eso como siempre recomendar la
cautela algunas voces críticas con el
estudio aseguran que no es tan claro que
la temperatura sea el único indicador al
final de que estos animales lograran
entrar en un estado de invernación de
invernación no y que por supuesto es muy
distinto un animal como un roedor
pequeño que un animal como un humano el
tamaño del cerebro es muy es muy
distinto también que por ahora se ha
logrado con 24 horas entonces bueno sin
embargo Pues también permitámonos soñar
no y ver que estas pequeñas pequeños
avances o pequeñas informaciones A dónde
nos pueden llevar en el futuro esa era
mi palabra final y es sueños de otros
mundos posibles veces a usted mal Muchas
gracias Ángela